COUNTRY.
GREAT SEEING YOU.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU.
PETE BUTTIGIEG IS THE FAVORITE
CANDIDATE OF WALL STREET, NOT
SURPRISINGLY.
THE MacKENZIE VETERAN.
HE'S FACING TROUBLE IN HIS OWN
CITY.
HE'S BEING DENOUNCED BY LOCALS
AFTER A POLICE OFFICER SHOT AND
KILLED AN AFRICAN AMERICAN MAN
WHO THE POLICE SAY WAS CUTTING
AT HIM WITH A KNIFE.
BUTTIGIEG CARES MORE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENCY THAN THE CITY HE
SUPPOSEDLY RUNS.
>> SURE, SURE --
>> EVERYONE CAN JUST -- WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW HIM TO SPEAK IF
EVERYBODY CAN CALM DOWN.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO FINISH -- I
WOULD LOVE TO FINISH MY REPLY IF
THAT'S OKAY.
>> Tucker: A FEW MINUTES AGO, WE
SHOWED YOU HIS SOLUTION TO THE
HECKLING.
HE SUGGESTED HIS OWN POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS PACKED WITH
RACISTS.
HARVEY MILLS IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE SOUTH BEND FRATERNAL ORDER
OF POLICE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
SO IS THE DEPARTMENT PACKED WITH
RACISTS, AS YOUR MAYOR SAYS.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THIS INCIDENT IS NOTHING TO DO
WITH RACE.
THIS INCIDENT IS ABOUT AN
OFFICER THAT WAS FORCED TO
DEFEND HIMSELF AGAINST A
DANGEROUS FELON WHO USED AN
EIGHT-INCH HUNTING KNIFE TO
ATTACK HIM.
THAT'S ALL THIS INCIDENT IS
ABOUT.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH SKIN
COLOR.
>> SO WHAT DOES IT DO TO SEE
RECKLESS SLIME BALL MAYOR IMPUGN
THE MORAL CHARACTER OF COPS
WITHOUT OFFERING ANY EVIDENCE AT
ALL, JUST DISMISSING THEM AS
RACIST?
WHAT DOES IT DO TO YOUR AVERAGE
POLICE OFFICER IN SOUTH BEND, TO
SEE SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
>> VERY DEMORALIZING, TUCKER.
HE USED THE TERM SYSTEMIC
RACISM.
MAYBE HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THE
DEFINITION OF SYSTEMIC.
WE DO.
THAT MEANS ALL.
HE'S BASICALLY CALLED ALL POLICE
OFFICERS RACIST.
THAT IS BLATANTLY UNTRUE.
>> Tucker: DOES HE HAVE EVIDENCE
OF THAT?
YOU'D THINK THIS IS A GUY THAT
WENT TO HARVARD SOMEHOW.
HE'S SUPPOSEDLY SMART AND
THOUGHTFUL, MORAL.
DOES HE HAVE ACTUAL EVIDENCE
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING CALLED
SYSTEMIC RACISM IN THE
DEPARTMENT OR IS HE SAYING THAT?
>> I BELIEVE HE'S JUST SAYING
IT.
I HAVE NOT HEARD ANY OF THAT.
THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT
THERE'S SYSTEMIC IN OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> Tucker: SO WHO WOULD WANT TO
BECOME A COP, IF YOUR OWN MAYOR
IS ATTACKING YOU ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION, OR ATTACKING WHAT
YOU DO AND WHO YOU ARE AS A MAN,
YOUR CHARACTER, WHO WOULD WANT
THE JOB?
DO YOU GET PAID ENOUGH TO WANT
TO PUT UP WITH CRAP LIKE THAT?
>> I'VE SERVED MY WHOLE LIFE.
FIRST IN THE NAVY AND NOW AS A
POLICE OFFICER.
IT REALLY COMES DOWN TO A WANT
TO SERVE THE COMMUNITY THAT YOU
LIVE IN.
THAT'S WHO WE HIRE.
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO HELP.
IT IS DIFFICULT IN TODAY'S
TIMES.
YOU KNOW, WITH SOME OF THE
CONTROVERSY GOING ON.
BUT COPS ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
THEY WANT TO HELP PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: IT'S A DIFFICULT JOB.
LET'S SAY THEORETICALLY THAT
YOUR MAYOR WAS NOT SPENDING HIS
TIME IN CNN STUDIOS AND BACK IN
SOUTH BEND AND YOU HAD A CHANCE
TO SPEAK WITH HIM ABOUT THIS,
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY?
>> I WOULD TELL HIM THAT HE
NEEDS TO RECUSE HIMSELF FROM
THIS INVESTIGATION.
HE HAS USED THIS INCIDENT TO
FURTHER HIS POLITICAL CAMPAIGN
AND HE CANNOT BE UNBIASSED ABOUT
THIS.
>> Tucker: SO RECKLESS ANT
WRONG.
THANK YOU, HARVEY.
>> THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO MENTION IF YOU
DON'T MIND, WE HAD START ADD GO
FUND ME PAGE TO HELP SUPPORT
OFFICER O'NEIL.
HOWEVER, GO OPPORTUNITY ME
ALLOWS ANTIFA TO RAISE MONEY ON
THEIR SITE, BUT THEY HAVE TAKEN
DOWN OUR SITE STATING THAT
OFFICER O'NEIL HAS BEEN ACCUSED
OF A HATE CRIME, WHICH IS
COMPLETELY UNTRUE.
WE HAVE STARTED A --
>> Tucker: GO FUND ME DO THAT?
>> YES, GO FUND ME.
YES.
WE'VE STARTED A NEW CAMPAIGN.
IT'S ON FUNDLY.COM.
YOU CAN HELP RYAN O'NEIL.
>> Tucker: THANKS.
AMAZING.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT GO FUND ME DO